- [Preston] My parents
said I could be anything,
so I became a guy.
And when I'm up on stage, I feel like
this is actually who I am.
(upbeat music)
My name is Preston Thomas
Martin and I'm a bodybuilder.
The Trans Bodybuilding
Competition is a bodybuilding
competition for trans men who are pre-
or post-op for their top surgery.
It's basically like a comfortable
setting that we can all
come to, those of us who love fitness.
This is the third year of the competition
and it's grown a lot
since it first started.
There's more competitors,
there's more people
that are coming out to see it,
it's just grown bigger and bigger.
- Quarter turn to the right.
- [Preston] I've always
watched the national
professional bodybuilders up
on stage and I'm just like,
"Aw man, I wanna be there one day."
And this Trans Bodybuilding Competition
has done that for trans people.
This is a comfortable setting for me
to do something that I love
to do and show off. (laughs)
I came to like bodybuilding because
I realized that it helped me a lot.
As far as my mental health goes,
bodybuilding is like therapy for me.
It helps me learn how to calm myself.
It makes you a stronger
person all the way around.
After transitioning, my perspective
on masculinity has changed a lot.
Even though it's been six years since
I've been transitioning,
I am still a sweetheart.
When I look in the mirror
now, I see a strong person,
but I have really had to look at my life
and everything that I have accomplished
and everything that I have been through
and been able to come back from.
The fact that I am happy
with my transition,
I'm happy with the way
that I'm turning out
and the way I'm looking, I'm happy
with how strong I'm becoming mentally.
I look in the mirror and
I can't help but smile.
I get excited. (laughs)